Je pensais que votre essai était intéressant,
vérifiez peut-être bien sur ces essais,
j'aime ceux qui sont parascolaires dans lesquels
vous n'êtes pas encore, mais maintenant les choses
vont plutôt bien, donc vous ne voulez pas
aller à l'université
Jessie Fisher Professeur Peter Oberg Je
sais que hyo n'est pas aussi  glamour comme New York
mais ils me préparent un
dîner de retraite quand est-ce le week-end du
25, vous savez, vérifiez votre emploi du temps en
vérifiant maintenant ah on dirait que je dois
changer certaines choses je serai là
il n'écrit jamais il n'appelle jamais oh  hé
quel était ce professeur Fairfield ouais
elle était comme le meilleur professeur que j'ai eu ici
elle était comme le deuxième meilleur professeur que j'ai
eu
Jessie c'est ma fille zippy hé salut
elle est en deuxième année quelle était ta majeure
j'étais anglais avec une mineure en histoire
fais juste  bien sûr que j'étais totalement inemployable
tu es comme à l'université tu es
trop habillé
je ne sais pas si tu le sais mais j'ai
quelques années de plus tu pensais que c'était
comme un romantique hein
je plaisante on se connecte avec un
p'tit non  tu ne penses pas  Je n'arrive pas à comprendre
si c'est parce que tu es avancé parce que
je suis rachitique parce que avancé qu'est-ce que
tu fous
Je ne sais pas si quelqu'un se sent comme un adulte
le sale secret du monde Je n'ai jamais rencontré
quelqu'un en qui j'avais confiance jusqu'à ce que je  j'ai 35 ans ça
ne me dérange pas
bien ça me dérange mon conseil est de
mettre une armure autour de ce petit plus gluant
une des choses que j'aime dans le fait d'être
ici était le sentiment que tout est
possible vous sortez de l'école et
tout pourrait  arriver
et ensuite vous sortez et la vie se passe
donc vous dites que je devrais me préparer
ou c'est nul de savoir qu'une
éducation en arts libéraux résout tous vos problèmes